[Music]
Mariah Carey is taking some time off to
unwind with her man Bryan Tanaka I've
been working on it's clear Mimi has been
working on her summer body - here's the
pop diva showing off her slim figure
while posing with her dancer beau the
couple appears to be enjoying the vacay
- a yacht taking turns playing photog
for the day
it seems Mimi couldn't resist snapping a
shirtless shot of Bryan looking calm and
collected he captioned the pic quote
when your girl says don't move I want to
take a picture of you you don't move the
48 year old singer is enjoying some
much-needed TLC while on a six-week
break from her Las Vegas residency
sometimes longer lengths Lea excursion
Mariah also canceled her Australia and
New Zealand tour dates this upcoming
October due to a scheduling conflict she
shared in a statement on her website
quote I promise to find new date soon
I've been working away on new music and
I cannot wait to share it with you later
this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]